or l'arrivée à new york se situe dans le
bouquin voyage au bout de la nuit
c'est le troisième yahia la guerre de 14
il ya l'afrique il ya des amériques et
léon juillet cher thierry je fais
l'intégrale l'intégralité le en juillet
à la gaîté montparnasse la période
américaine et l'installation du docteur
destouches à la garenne rend si ces
trois heures vingt de spectacle une
prolongation ça va dans l'état rural
alors bon bah quand on quand on voit le
spectacle effectivement une première
première phrase c'est new york verticale
figurez vous qu'elle était debout leur
ville absolument droite absolument
droite
new york c'est une ville debout avec ses
très bons ça a été écrit en 1928 il faut
aller voir fabrice est une très bonne
façon de rentrer dans ces lignes c'est
d'aller voir fabrice non restituée
djibou marché avec moi ouais ya la vidéo
de vos marchés description aussi des
chiottes de new york est incroyable
c'est comment toutefois un moment donné
le policeman du milieu de la chaussée
poser comme un encrier nos mythes se mit
à ceux suspectés d'avoir des drôles de
projets voilà c'était visible ou qu'on
se trouve dès qu'on attire sur soi
l'attention des autorités de mieux et de
disparaître et en vitesse pas
d'explication au gouffre que je me dis à
droite de mon banc s'ouvre est
précisément un trou large à même le
trottoir dans le genre du métro de chez
nous se trompent paru propice à une
telle beauté se trouve paru propice
propice probants
[Applaudissements]
puis monique séka matière du spectacle
un tiers le plus poignant de ce qui a
été écrit à mon avis non indépassable
indépassable ce qu'ils déclarent d'une
tonne près peut-être françois villon
non c'est extraordinaire dans votre
spectacle c'est que vous nous dites pas
ces lignes vous ne lisez pas vous ne
restez pas voulu restituer d'accord
quand on arrive vers ces heures-là en
eau du thon kolenc oui on aperçoit au
delà du grand lac de nuit qui est sûr le
cimetière les plumes hier les premières
lumières de rancy francis et des clichy
les premières lumières de rang si c'est
sur l'autre bord en 6 faut faire tout le
tour pour y arriver c'est si loin
alors on dirait qu'on fait le tour de la
nuit même tellement il faut marcher ne
pas autour du cimetière pour arriver aux
fortifications et puis ayant atteint la
porte à le croire pour la mémoire
j'ai essayé de faire à une intervention
du quartier il a un soldat et une panne
de boncolac ourbise huitième déjà bon
vous êtes du même quartier des paris
sauf que lui il a les virus qui nous
valent à châteauroux va bien sûr y
habitent là jamais renier en norvège et
ça m'a plu moi j ai vite et plus fort
voilà vous restituer de céline plutôt
que vous le dites oui il faut ici le
récit tué alors la difficulté c'est
d'essayer ne pas restituer les mots
ouais ce qu'il faut essayer c'est de
comprendre enfin de comprendre pas
tellement nombreux à s'essayer d'être en
coïncidence avec l'esprit qui a été l'un
à l'impulsion d'une phrase est une
ambition qui est énorme qu'est ce qui
s'est passé quand rimbaud a écrit à les
retrouver quoi l'éternité
alors le mec peut le dire le faire
c'était tant qu'on veut sur ce qu'on
peut dire allez retrouver quoi
l'éternité toi on peut tout dire comment
il l'a lui éprouvé c'est un projet
bizarre la restitution
voilà le problème de l'acteur c'est la
restitution voilà alors souvent vous
reprenez des phrases vous reprenez des
phrases vous reprenez des phrases
jusqu'à ce que le public les ai bien
compris
je reprends des phrases parce que
d'abord j'y suis pas tout tout le temps
et j'essaye comme un musicien d'essayer
de retrouver
j'ai la chance d'avoir la liberté de
décider de me dire tiens là j'en ai j'ai
chargé
et puis c'est tellement étonnamment beau
qu'il faut pas se laisser aller qu'à
l'histoire
bref je sais que c'est quelqu'un qui est
tous dans la salle par exemple si je
sens que c'est une toux qui n'est pas
affirmative
je l'intègre en disant ah là un problème
de tous cette personne donc au contraire
je suis plein d'amour ou comptera pas
plein d'amour
si je sens une toux arrogante la touche
et payer 220 balle et je t'emmerde est
emmerdé qu'on s'attaque là je peux
arrêter le riche peut lui dire c'est
embêtant et des apartés 2d incidente pas
tout le temps mais pas tous une fois
bouquet michel l'acteur grands acteurs
français enfin le grand le plus grand
acteur français
je vois une pièce de félicien marceau
j'essaye de l'intéressé parce qu'il ne
donne pas du tout de se sentir seul
morceau pour l'intérêt félicien marceau
c'est un auteur de théâtre et puis
michel bouquet je vois une pièce ça
s'appelait l'oeuf et alors il sortait
d'un oeuf et pendant quelques minutes il
ne disait rien je sais ils étaient
immobiles comme ça et le public est
tellement plus habitué à être très
discret dans le théâtre qu'il y en a qui
disait il a vieilli bon et qu'il est une
affaire totalement gracial sorte de
touche pas à mon pote une incarnation
l'anguienne de la réalité de la tête
quand même choisi 90 quand tu fais un
classement vous êtes un acteur de cinéma
très bien payés oui beaucoup d'argent
vous faites un film aujourd'hui c'est
énorme et vous êtes là à faire découvrir
céline à des gens dans un théâtre qui
est pas très grand c'est un non mais
c'est quoi c'est un sacerdoce non pas
pour y être ado villa à saint tropez à
l'île maurice avec des blondes
décolorées des hors-bord et enfin avoir
une énorme capacité fans il faut être
très fort pour savoir être à deauville
ou vacances tragiquement faut avoir un
un état psychique ou sur deux soit
supérieur à la moyenne
moi je trouve que c'est surtout les gens
qui travaillent pas qui devrait être
récompensé parce qu'il ya un courage
ouais c'est un courage énorme parce que
ce divertissement dont pascal doc
ce mécanisme du divertissement dont
parle thomass beernaert un auteur
formidable qui écrit ddd livre
uniquement musicalement
tu connais pas du tout hamas beernaert
le neveu de wigan stein c'est très beau
c'est sur glane comme le voilà est-ce
que je vais cette famille est ce que tu
connais la longue houle louis allemand
[Applaudissements]
glenn gould le plus grands pianistes du
monde
these pas le cousin barbara gould et
voit imperturbable
je continue mon interview non
sérieusement il ya quand même c'est un
sacerdoce salon dans sa les regards oui
je ne serai pas être capable d'être ni
fut un tarp et en ce doux pour les
scieries ni penser on est rendu là même
heure de 18e à dater inquiétant et au
collège à mon âge je ne vais pas j'ai
besoin de travailler et le métier
d'acteur si on n'a pas la chance d'avoir
la scène qui est l'endroit où on est
anobli où on est au service de quelque
chose de sublime je vois pas qu'est ce
qu'on va faire toute la journée enfin je
n'ai pas d'aptitude est normal dans
l'existence sauf que de me dire le matin
je vais essayer de jouer encore plaisir
dans la seule c'est un plaisir d'essayer
d'améliorer le morceau comme a dit
guitry la seule chose qui est formidable
dans le métier d'acteur de théâtre et
qu'on se dit que demain on jouera
peut-être un tout petit peu mieux que la
veille
pas de moi c'est guitry vous allez
rencontrer l'oeuvre de céline dans le
quartier des abbesses eau provient d'un
prêtre jean claude barreau jean claude
barreau il s'occupait de la colle de
marwa revenant il trône jeu jean claude
barreau qui est un petit très beau très
beau il ya bint homonyme
il ya une sublime moto c'est encore un
ami on égale à l'ensemble et le prêtre
des vrais voyous ceux qui tuent des gens
parce que voilà le voiture à la passe
que le 18e avant d'être devenu un
endroit branché moitié 50 ans je peux en
parler
c'était un endroit extrêmement difficile
les abbesses n'est pas du tout un
endroit où la mode et ça c'était pas la
bastille c'était un endroit où
angoissant magnifique les cette
merveilleuse phrase de sénestis doc
gynéco qui parle d'eceh d'un très beau
livre qui s'appelle la maison des morts
alors fabrice quand on vous parle
évidemment des écrits antisémites de
céline vous dites je ne veux pas être
l'avocate céline je défends son style
pas ses idées et ce qu'explique
finalement vous dites sur
l'antisémitisme c'est son dégoût de soi
même c'est sa façon de l'extérioriser
voyait les choses plus riches à dire
qu'on était dite en plus - love qui
m'intéresse c'est les deux premiers
livres
donc c'est 1932 et 1934 après le céline
après à par ferry pour une autre fois je
suis pas comme certains grands
intellectuels qui est mieux nord d'un
château l'autre ça donc les problèmes
politiques sont arrivés en 30
je crois que les premiers pamphlet à sa
faim sont arrivés à saint louis després
flec wade reflets oui mais en cause d d
d d d d d d êtres fin des professions de
foi des trucs
ceci dit la n allais total 1 chez céline
hâle est attendu à l'époque talal et
globale
alors évidemment elle s'est fixé sur les
juifs et des protestants mais elle est
globale moi mon truc c'est que j'aime le
chef-d'oeuvre j'aime pas l'individu
m'intéresse moyennement dans la mesure
que ce qui me plaît c'est l'effort
littéraire de le c'est pour ça qu'on
roule quand j'étais adolescent à 22 ans
quand j'ai eu le voyage au bout de la
nuit dans les mains et j'ai appris qu'il
n'était pas un mec bien avec les
tragiques geste était dans une sorte de
ram et un peu un grand bal bien tu as
une adolescente voudrez aimé adoré et
qui le dit c'est pas possible que ce
génie là a pu être cet homme là donc tu
refuses bien un jour tu lis l'élite du
lit et pendant des années tu dis c'est
pas possible d'aimer quelqu'un qui est
comme ça c'est comme une et à un moment
tu après avec la maturité tu te dis que
l'oeuvre est une chose que l'individu en
est une autre
oui vous dites l'allitération mais pas
nécessairement associée à de nobles
sentiments effectivement aussi danseur
n'est pas lié aux bons sentiments non ce
manuscrit du voyage qui a été vendu 11
millions de francs plus entre les mains
quelques heures de lyon avec les frais
avec les frères y avait 4000 en toi non
je montais psychiquement les gens
n'aient jamais pu on épouse était là
jamais pas faire le moindre truc elle
n'a pas arrêté de me dire quand ils ont
commencé à monter les halles dizaines de
bouge pas fabresse et je les ai eu dans
les mains n'a une journée entière et je
vais le lire à la bibliothèque
finalement prendre dans les biotech
nationale vous faites en ce moment une
campagne d'information la télévision
pour les économies d
j'ai alors 50% dé la consommation
d'énergie et d'émissions de gaz
carbonique est due aux particuliers
c'est ce qu'on apprend dans cette
campagne
vous faite sabre et l'argent parce que
vous croyez qu'il faut préserver la
planète
d'abord faut le faire parce que c'est un
projet qui était bien écrit par un un
publiciste admirable s'appelle monnier
nicolas est évidemment je l'aurais pas
fait gratuitement parce que je l'aurais
moins bien fait il faut surtout pas
faire les choses gratuitement parce que
c'est ça qui est merveilleux dans
l'argent c'est que ça enlève le problème
de la dette
pourquoi les gens vont voir les top en
ce doux parce qu'il n'ya plus d'affect
ya plus un projet sur toi on it entame
pas puisque tu payes personne n'est lésé
son manque d'amour a dû tourner en rond
d'amour trop déçu